what's going on reject nation back at it
again now they have dropped the trailer
forces Sam now full disclosure we don't
really know much about Shazam but I'm
wearing a DC shirt anyway just to seem
like I do anyway let's just hop right
into this you've run from foster homes
in six counties I can take care of
myself
when you're eighteen give these people a
chance because that's what they're
giving you
this is Willie Batson
it's ready make him feel at home it
should be nice don't why it gets real
king of thrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're just able to
posture kid you've got it all away from
this conversation well your family to
stand up for you
lili-beth
I choose you
Plus GP
hello say my name I don't know your name
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
in this thing funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're dead
[Music]
[Music]
I have ridiculous faith in this that
looks awesome
so much fun I don't know anything about
Shazam the comic and literally halfway
through them like I want to know more
about Shazam the comics honestly like
the thing that got me most excited about
this trailer is the fact that this is
new to me and this is a chance for the
DCU to kind of reestablish themselves in
my eyes was something I'm not familiar
with I don't have expectations for and
this just looks so much fun and also
from David Sandberg who did like lights
out yeah so to see him tackling a
totally different territory it seems to
have a commentary on the superhero genre
as well which I'm excited for cuz that's
a unique thing - yeah the humor just
looks really natural yeah everything
about the humor looks natural you know I
know there was a little shifting phase
where some people had issues with the
way the humor was being handled in DC
especially with like Justice League or
something here this feels very organic
it doesn't look like a Christmas movie -
yeah this looks like a fun Christmas
movie and I think the chemistry between
when he's a kid with the other kid and
then when he's Zachary Levi and the kid
whoever they the kid is was disabled
he's doing a great job - I feel like
he's gonna be a standout performer isn't
he Eddie from it yeah it is Eddie from
it but that even looked charming and it
almost reminded me of big yeah which is
just a cool aspect of Bri I never would
have thought of that for a comic-book
movie it's kind of this like big
coming-of-age tale mixed with the
superhero genre all that stuff with the
soup I was invested in it before he even
became a superhero like this is looking
like a great film
this guy's a kid and I love the unique
Shazam as a character I'm not shy to
admit that I don't really know much
about because I know a lot of people
don't really know much about him and I
think that when you see this trailer
you're gonna want to go find out who
Shazam is because that's a dream concept
right there to play into that childhood
fantasy do an adult superhero so
watching Zachary Levi with a child
personality as a superhero just seems
like a total blast well it looks like
the funning game stuff is gonna be
pretty fun towards i walking around
charging people's phone yeah yeah look
at that light
and all that is I'm bulletproof almost
reminded me of like the first spider-man
you know like ship fly in terms of tone
I kind of get a first spider-man meets
sort of like an ant-man vibe yeah yeah
yeah with a little bit of that amazing
spider-man shaky-cam through this just
really gets me excited to to see more of
the DC characters and I'm not familiar
with yes this could be their chance to
really define like you know you got to
have Superman and Batman and the Maine
heavies but this makes me optimistic for
them I like the humor and a lot of the
live action DC shows and I kind of feel
like they've brought a lot of that blend
into here as well yeah this feels great
yeah I'm so excited for this movie
arguably the trailer that's made me most
happy I was just very surprised by its
like I expect a cool comic book trailer
and then I watch this trailer I'm like I
feel joy when I thank you thanks DC this
looks awesome because the trailer takes
its time it doesn't look it's a it's a
cool slick edited trailer it feels like
you're watching what the movie will be
oh yeah well and also I do appreciate
the restraint they used with the villain
you know because it's getting me
anticipating that and wondering what the
Detailers are gonna be I mean as soon
that's more strong it is more strong
yeah and like some of those little
flashes like in the subway car where the
lights are flickering yeah seems like
maybe David Sandberg is gonna get to use
some of that horror you know toolbox
yeah or even when he gets the powers
from the mystical looking dude you know
see that look cool that look cool tune
it can play a little cheesy but they the
humor they use they're made up for it
yeah all right oh man the surprise what
do you guys think of the Shazam trailer
and how great does this look you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us on
patreon full like TV show reactions
weekly q and A's music video coverage
we'd love to have you become a patron
object today
[Music]